it's quickly become apparent that Jared
Kushner the 36 year old real estate
investor and husband at the banca Trump
is president Donald Trump's most trusted
advisor within his inner circle a circle
whose top tier includes chief strategist
Steve Bannon and chief of staff Reince
Priebus now it's pretty easy to know
where Priebus and Bannon stand
politically as chairman of the
Republican National Committee for five
years Priebus is the voice of the
Republican establishment and as the
former editor of Breitbart Bannon
champions the populist economic
nationalism that appealed to so many of
trumps working-class voters it's
important to know where Trump's key
advisors stand on the issues because
it's almost impossible to know where
Trump himself stands Trump's not an
ideologue he's a pragmatist who's
changed his views multiple times
throughout the years when it comes down
to it his political goals are basically
this we're gonna win win win you're
gonna get so tired of winning you're
going to say mr. president please we
don't want to win anymore it's so much
of all Trump's advisors tasked with this
charge of winning for the American
people
Jared Kushner is the most important but
also the least understood we simply
don't know where he stands politically
and there are a few reasons for that
Kushner is only 36 years old he's got no
history in politics and it's clear that
even two or three years ago being a top
adviser to the most powerful man in the
world wasn't remotely on his radar his
last big project was buying this cluster
of Brooklyn buildings from the Jehovah's
Witnesses in 2013 for 375 million in
order to turn it into hipstery office
space Kushner and the vodka too for that
matter has always been a sort of hybrid
of the left-leaning hipster generation
and the older mega rich business elite
Jared was certainly born into wealth and
lots of it but his family didn't start
out that way
both his paternal grandparents were
Holocaust survivors thankfully making it
to the United States in 1949 where
Gerry's grandfather Joseph a
construction worker started building and
managing New Jersey apartments his son
Jared's father Charles then started
acquiring real estate turning Kushner
companies
business into a billion-dollar empire
this is the world that Jared Kushner
grew up in it was deeply religious Jared
was brought up in Modern Orthodox
Judaism massively wealthy and privileged
Jared was conveniently accepted to
Harvard after his parents pledged 2.5
million dollars to the University and
actually quite democratic Charles
Kushner was one of the most prominent
donors to Democratic politicians on the
East Coast in fact he was the largest
single donor to the 2000 New York Senate
campaign of Hillary Clinton and then
things came apart New jersey-based
developer Charles Kushner is charged
with hiring a prostitute to blackmail
two witnesses in a federal investigation
where he is a target charles conviction
was deeply traumatic for Jared as of
course it would be it shook up his
entire life and not just emotionally but
professionally too at the age of just 24
Jared took over the massive Empire his
father Bill he wasted little time making
a splash of his own in 2007 Kushner
companies bought an office building at
666 Fifth Avenue in Manhattan for 1.8
billion dollars the most expensive
single building purchase in US history
unfortunately it was really bad timing a
year later the economy collapsed and 666
has not been able to generate enough
money for Kushner companies to pay off
the debt even today but despite this
setback Kushner kept data he kept making
deals or trying to like the trendy tech
office space in Brooklyn it's clear that
he's focused and driven and ambitious
but a success or failure in real estate
tells us preciously little about where
his mind's at politically for all I know
he could still sympathize with the
democratic values that his father funded
so generously
the truth is Kushner seems a bit out of
place in the conservative populist
nationalist white house of Donald Trump
until you account for two things first
his loyalty to family Kushner always
sticks by his own when his father was
put away he didn't abandon him and when
Trump retweeted wittingly or not some
anti-semitic imagery alongside a picture
of Hillary Clinton last summer Kushner
wrote an op-ed defending him in the New
York Observer
newspaper that he owns that's the second
place to look for hints of Kushner's
politics the observer it was here that
he developed a friendship even a
mentorship with Rupert Murdoch the media
magnate and owner of Fox News Murdoch
Council Jared gave him advice sent over
books by prominent conservative thinkers
and soon the paper began to take on a
more right-wing Ben some say Kushner
even had a vindictive streak using the
paper to go after people who wronged him
or his family like for example New York
Attorney General Eric Schneiderman who
investigated Trump University the hit
piece The Observer published on
Schneiderman is almost comical in its
defense of Trump scam school a lot of
people saw the same vindictiveness in
the ouster of Chris Christie from
Trump's transition team last December
Christie of course was the man who sent
Jarrod's father to jail mr. Koechner
engaged in a conspiracy with
co-conspirators to hire prostitutes this
period is where Kushner may have begun
to acquire more conservative values but
I have to be fair and say that these are
just Inklings of what may be in his mind
you barely ever put things on the record
he barely ever speaks to the media what
we do know is that today Kushner is
overseeing a laundry list of things in
Trump's administration including heading
the new office of American innovation
being the key liaison for diplomats from
China Mexico and a dozen other countries
and of course there's this if you can
produce peace in the Middle East
nobody can in most things Trump's and
Kushner are opposites
one is loud easily distracted and media
obsessed the other is understated
focused and media allergic but they both
trust sampling and Trump definitely
trusts Jared Kushner for president with
such little grasp on policy and detail
that means Jared Kushner might just be
the most influential person in the world
it would sure be nice to know a little
more about what he believes
oh my god this guy's okay well hey
everybody thank you so much for watching
happy Wednesday this episode was brought
to you by Squarespace if you want to
make a website and you want it to be a
really easy process Squarespace has some
beautiful award-winning designer
templates to choose from that makes the
process so simple if I can make a
website on there which I did I guarantee
you can too got 24 hour customer service
no upgrades nothing to install no
patches ever and thinking your domain
name is really you can start your free
trial at squarespace.com and use the
offer code nerdwriter
you can get 10% off your first purchase
you can subscribe to this channel by
clicking the circle that's right over
there and you can watch the last episode
about Jack Nicholson and anger right
there I think you'll really like it I'll
see you guys next Wednesday